this was downtown greenville it burned  to the ground on wednesday and days  later remains wreathed in smoke that  gives it an eerie post-apocalyptic feel  the heat was so intense it melted this  lamppost  and the rest of downtown was pretty much  leveled  this is the worst wildfire in the united  states right now and the second largest  in california history but it's one of  more than a hundred fires in 15 states  being battled by 26 000 firefighters and  they've got their job cut out for them  you can see here this was a century-old  hotel and now only the facade remains  what's happened is that global warming  has exacerbated the dry and hot  conditions that make it easier for a  spark to set off a fire so 2020 was the  worst fire season yet and 2021 is  expected to be worse still  [Music]  you